J'ai été impliqué dans l'original Point
Break et le surf nous saisissons toujours les
quelques films qui tentent de capturer l'esprit
de ce que signifie le surf et que le surf
est vraiment plus une philosophie Point
Break a capturé NAT ce Point Break d'
ajouter de grosses vagues surfant sur les plus grosses
vagues  dans le monde, je suis juste un grand
fan de l'original, il
réinvente maintenant un Point Break, nous avons essentiellement
pris tout ce que vous aimez dans le
film original et l'
avons agrandi  J'inclus maintenant également le
surf de remorquage bien la personne qui m'a
appris à aller pour Whistler Hamilton
tout ce qui concerne ce film n'est que
le niveau supérieur, l'original était un
niveau à son époque et maintenant c'est au
niveau de cette époque  chofu est l'une des
vagues les plus féroces et les plus meurtrières au monde
et nous avons eu les meilleurs surfeurs du monde
faisant des choses qui n'ont jamais
été faites à Teahupoo avant qu'ils aient
demandé de faire ce reste fait qui est le
la vague de shara qui est super dangereuse
alors Bruce est en quelque sorte descendu droit je
viens voler profondément le croisement
dans lequel je tombe et je regarde en arrière j'étais tellement
époustouflé par le regard en arrière et j'allais
bien j'avais ma ligne et puis il a juste
disparu  avec la lance et ensuite nous
venons tous les deux de voler probablement l'une
des meilleures choses que j'ai jamais faites dans la
vague déjà ce que font les caméramans
prend juste un plus grand risque car
les surfeurs vont-ils là-bas avec une
quantité phénoménale d'équipement  les hélicoptères
et les drones profitent d'une tête de stabilisation
personne ne va croire que cela a
été fait pour de vrai c'était si gros
dans cette crise qui a peut-être été faite avec
des effets visuels mais ce n'est pas Paul l'
océan je veux dire c'est comme les gars qui
font du snowboard se font prendre dans un  avalanche,
je veux dire, nous sommes pris dans une avalanche à
chaque vitesse, la puissance peut enfoncer
votre corps dans Laurie Tanner dont Butte
est le meilleur gars du tofu en fait lors de
sa première vague fermée sur lui, il vient de
descendre fort un  et tout droit vers le
bas, je me suis cogné la tête et, en gros,
je ne me souviens pas quand je me suis cogné la tête pour être dans
l'eau calme et le lagon qui est
probablement le pire ou le plus
effrayant que j'ai eu. J'ai vraiment de la chance que le
surf soit le plus facile  partie survivant taille
ce n'est pas vraiment un remake car on
ne cherche pas à raconter la même histoire
mais ça garde définitivement des éléments
du premier le film qui
nous a inspiré à
chaque fois qu'on est invité dans un
projet de jeu qui a la réputation d'un
film comme  le Point Break original avait je
pense que c'est un honneur pour
toi